hello everyone there are a lot of strong
chess tournaments going on in the world
the sheriff masters just finished
there's the US Championship but perhaps
the strongest tournament that is
currently being held is the Shanker
chess tournament in Azerbaijan and
that's basically a tournament held in
the honor of Google gershenoff an
excellent chess player both both in
blitz and in classical chess Fukushima
was ranked number six in the world in
them in November of 2009 and he he might
have who knows how far he might have
gotten if he had his health
unfortunately in the year 2000 he was
the diagnosed with epilepsy but it was a
very soon discovered that it was
actually a brain tumor and you know he
continued playing chess but I'm sure
that the the disease did take its toll
and on his on his chest and life of
course and that's I'm probably going to
show a couple of games played in this
tournament the shampoo chess tournament
as it features a lot of strong players
and here I prepared even the table for
you the this is these are the pairings
from round 2 you can see that there are
three players from Azerbaijan Timur a
job of around Mamedov and also char
clear mamedyarov so three excellent
players from Azerbaijan that are
fighting some of the strongest players
in the world here we have Magnus Carlsen
there's onigiri reading leerin Sergey
kurakin and of course we have a rather
slow voyage again David navara this is a
print screen from round 2 and we have we
see that car can already drew his game
against England I was a it's they
blitzed out all the moves and it was a
very quick draw but yeah that's that's
basically what I wanted to say and if
you ask anyone in the world who ever
played against the gushy move or even
just met him they will only have words
of praise for him but yeah I'll put a
couple of useful links in the
description below as usual plus an
article from
New York Times about about about you
know his life and and his chess
it's from 2014 and unfortunately in 2014
in January
bugarach Ashima off has left this world
so that was very unfortunate he was
getting treatment for his for his brain
tumor in Germany and while receiving
that treatment he died and because I
will show you a couple of games probably
from this tournament that is held in the
honor of Fukushima I decided to show you
a game played by Google she moved in the
last tournament he played the last
tournament Fukushima played was the Tata
Steel chess tournament in 2012 and this
is probably the last game he won in in a
big tournament I mean since this is the
last tournament he played this is
definitely the last game he won in in
such a great tournament so let's see
this game his opponent is uneasy veeery
who has the white pieces and Amish opens
with E 4 we have C 5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 and d4 so
awkwardly standard C captors Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
now we have a 6 Bishop to g5 we have
Knight B to d7 the knight of variation
already as you've seen the a6 move
Bishop to c4 now we have Queen to a5
attacking the bishop on g5 also pinning
the knight on c3 Queen to d2 now now you
can't capture on e4 anymore since the
knight is no longer pinned and the Queen
is now protecting the bishop on g5 we
have e 6
Gabri castles Queen side and now b5 and
here get replace Bishop to d5 Bishop to
b3 seems Bishop to b3 seems like a
reasonable move but Bishop to d5
obviously are prepared variation and
here
Kashima ignores the better he plays
before if you capture the bishop for
example pawn captures Bishop on d5 you
get Knight to c6 first and in between
move that takes advantage of the
awkwardly placed Queen and a 5 and after
Queen moves back then you get it capped
or sundry 5 now the knight is protected
on c6 and rook hd1 is coming
definitely
for white regardless of white being a
piece down but after Bishop to d5 gushy
move isn't interested in the piece he
plays before he sacrifices the exchange
but he will have compensation as you'll
see in the game
we have Bishop captures on a 8b captors
on c3 and now you see the problem you
can't capture with the Queen if you
capture the Queen you lose this Bishop
on g5 this is what check so after this B
captors on c3 you have to play B captors
on c3 and now you get Queen captures on
a2 and yes white is up the exchange but
black is already threatening Queen to a1
checkmate
so Queen t2 making room for the king so
the King cannot escape via d2 and d1
Bishop to e7 Bishop to e7 is played with
the threat of Knight capturing on e4 and
then this will open up an attack from
the bishop to the bishop on g5 King to
d2 getting the King to a safer Square
and now Knight captures only four with
Czech Queen captures and Bishop captures
on g5 this is also with check
we have f4 and now the shimmer should
definitely retreat which is Bishop but
if he does so immediately for example
Bishop to e6 then this would be met with
Knight to f5 this would come with an
attack on the bishop on h6 also now the
pawn on d6 is under attack the pawn is
pinned you can never capture the night
so instead after this f4 move agasshi
move doesn't retreat with the bishop
instead he plays d5 first and now Geary
is basically forced to move his queen
now if he plays something like Queen to
e3 you get Bishop to f6 now moving the
bishop to a safer Square and now Knight
to a5 no longer makes sense as there is
nothing to attack on a6 and there is
nothing to attack on d6 so here white
isn't worse well might be slightly worse
but you have a king Gandhi - you
definitely don't want to play this so
after this d5 move Gary decided to give
back material and he played rook to a-1
we have Queen captures on a1 rook
captures anyone and now D captures on e
4f captors on g5 and now h6 so at this
moment gushy move is a
a pawn but soon that will that will be
rectified g6 hoping to hoping to ruin
gushy moves pawn structure as he does
have double D points if he captures now
here then he will also have double G
pawns and he's not interested in this he
plays f5 and we have Knight captures on
e6 so given a d6 pawn but maintaining a
very strong doubled pawn here not to
double but to two points that are
protected with the upon being a passed
pawn so King to e7 attacking the knight
Knight to f4 and now rook to d8
threatening some discoveries like nice
to be six winning a bishop on a eight so
bishop on da a bishop but to d5 bishop
moves Knight to b6 attacking the bishop
and now c4 and here go she wins the pawn
back now knife captures on c4 now the
bishop is spin so again gosh you move is
up upon King to c3 and now Knight the e3
attacking the bishop on d5 twice Bishop
to f7 and now comes rope to d6 we have
rook to a5 Bishop to d7 and now give it
plays rook to e5 check it's a bit of an
unnecessary check because it allows
allows gushing of skink to enter the
position King to f6 and now the king is
coming to g5 we have rocked back to c5
and now King to g5 attacking the knight
b3 defending the knight and now Knight
to f1 attacking the h2 pawn h4 check
King moves and now there is no way to
protect the g3 pawn rope to d5 rook
captures Knight captures and now King
captures and g3 Kashima is now up two
points and well this is now more or less
a question of technique Knight to f6
going for the e pawn III now Bishop to
c4 Bishop to b5 we have kept Bishop nice
to h5 check so even this can be allowed
King to f2 and now comes the Knight
captures on b7 on g7 so even even Geary
now has a passed pawn already on g6 but
there is no time to take advantage of
this Bishop captures on c4 King capers
on c4 and now e2
it was in this position that uneasy
resigned the game because there is there
is really nothing you can do here what
is too slow if you capture or it doesn't
matter if you go anywhere else
black post simply grab a queen and there
is nothing you can do here
black will simply give a check and he
will be in time to stop every anything
and there are no tricks with the white
knight so yeah
after this he to move unusually resigned
the game so yeah this was the last
tournament bugarach team of played it
was the Tata Steel chess tournament 2012
and here I even have a photo of
Fukushima let me just check oh yeah here
it is this is a photo taken it's not a
photo it's a basically a print screen
from the video from the Tata Steel
official YouTube channel but this is
this is him right after this game so he
is giving an interview after his game
with onigiri so as you can see he is
very happy and definitely does not look
like someone that will be that will
leave the world in in well in
approximately two years as both Tata
Steel is held in January and as I've
said Mughal regime of died in January of
2014 so a great loss for the for the
chess world for the world in general
even greater loss for other Azerbaijan
such as such a chess power nation having
like we've said chakra media of Timor
the job of Ralph Mamedov and of course
probably maybe even one of the greatest
chess players of all times comes from
Baku Azerbaijan there is of course Garry
Kasparov the Beast of Baku so yeah I
mean a terrible terrible loss and you
know it's always always very hard once
when something like this happens so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah like I said I will be covering
a couple of games from shrunk shank your
chess tournament 2018 so I just wanted
to share this with you and I wanted you
to know why it was played and in whose
honor it was played so yeah it was in
honor of Fukushima and
now you all know who he was and
hopefully I will learn something more
about him as I will add a couple of
useful links in the description below so
yeah that's it I would like to thank
Durrell Severus Rossi Akhtar Nadi
Merrifield joseph Morgan and Mohammad
Reza
Rosa for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with with another interesting
video thank you